[Musique]
bravo
plus tôt
oui
[Musique]
m
wahaha
mais
quoi
pour les eaux
oh
moi
m
[Musique]
embarquement immédiat now boarding marco
immédiate au welsh et lunettes noires
pour nuit blanche le top ch au programme
est tellement tard le samedi soir qu'il
finira par être diffusée le dimanche
matin à la place de la messe
vous verrez en couverture du nme et de
lunettes la même semaine simpl mind
exclu m'a lu à haute couture gauthier
interview jean paul génial génial génial
anti portrait chinois navarre la bagarre
arrange le portrait de la rive gauche
alta to stop basta c'est le type de
samedan ressemblant énormément
esthétique helvétique et synthétique
y'ello et l'oma lui michael hoffman
reprise du gaby de bashung à vos
souhaits mesdames messieurs les là et
plus nous de que deux c'est impossible
star buyster 100% pur son spécial
jacking allumer les warnings façonnent
les sites belges pour en finir avec les
80 rouge le carton garantit le baston
nightclubbing sylvain bergère cette
semaine la capitale est un carnaval
dana le cartooniste contre margera le
bédéiste faux de faire un dessin du sien
lens treille va-t-elle être le slip de
chirac barre ou giscard question très
très très très con
ce mot
et marquer des essais
os x
[Musique]
la main voici donc lunettes noires le
magazine qui vous mange de la télévision
et ça commence avec bobby la bouche les
[ __ ] c'est ce plateau de la semaine
après l'une est la france sera mûr pour
les [ __ ] vertes
6 m
tickets
je
m
plus jamais la mort
[Musique]
et
jeudi
[Musique]
mais j'avais
le sait
[Musique]
ouais
m
en fait
je ne sais pas
chacun d'eux dit
sauver la mort
voudrait-elle se réincarner en slip
défoncé le portrait de david et johnatan
un brin fantômes ou charden de quoi tel
le plus peur laurence treille des
sources de vittel au marais de la
vouivre elle assure maman alors on très
bon soir tu vas pas y couper
on va commencer par ces mois sur reste
combien de choses c'est ça on va y venir
d'abord combien tu mesures mais 84 1 m
84 mais c'est parce c'est pas
réfrigérant un peu pour les mecs
non il y en a comme ça il y en a qui
aiment ça oui puis toute façon j'ai un
compagnon qui est aussi grand que moi
donc tout va bien a bon effet combien il
fait un mètre 84 aussi le poids 62 kg
rolala le relais les orges tu sais 86-86
la taille 60 ces vieux salade de quatre
ans lors de ses passes la taille 62 4
way la poitrine alors là la poitrine non
je veux pas gérable si très peu très peu
oui c'est un chiffre que c'est un
chiffre non mais c'est si les traits il
est très inégale fausse beaucoup de
choses parce que ça fait 1 95 alors que
c'est des petits bonnets ce parce que je
suis la route d'ici mais voilà ces trois
quarts la mesure dans les chaussures
quarante deux 42 tenir bon alors ton
corps et que la mobilité c'est assez ça
commençait par un truc très connue c'est
bon tu as été au cours de théâtre à
l'âge de 16 ans quelle heure après il ya
eu vite elle c'est là que tout le monde
a craqué sur toi avant vitaly l'équipe
mais il était de voyance qu il m'a aidé
à faire vite elle parce que sinon on
voulait tellement dans les films à bord
on s'est tous mis à boire de la zone
vitale surtout bon alors là il ya la
vouivre qui marche très très bien
oui c'est quand même ça fait d'entrer à
peu près non je sais pas j'ai jamais eu
d'entente à nancy pape sy au pourcentage
je fais ce genre de d'angoise aux
producteurs ou
vous mettez en scène c'est un très beau
film tenu tout le temps chez minutes où
le temps oui je suis abonné non parce
que c'est pas une c'est pas une nudité
contemporaine si je puis dire c'est
s'est gelé mais c'est sublime et c'est
une déesse de toute façon à ça même pas
ce que c'est qu'un maître loin alors
voilà et puis je suis toujours habillée
de mou j'étais ravi d'ailleurs pour ça
c'est que tous les malades dans les
débuts d'ee comme fille
dans la vie je suis pudique fou mais n'a
pas davantage fait quoi quand même je me
balade à poil mais la pudeur et se place
pas forcément là je suis pudique autre
part oui j'ai des côtés très pudique qui
sont pas forcément à rattacher à beauxis
va quitter marjah l'âge de 18 ans mais
c'est vrai mais toujours avec le même
homme n'est pas cet idéal alors c'est
pas que celui peut-être envie de me
poser ses on sait jamais dans un mariage
on est deux dans un mariage
si je suis je suis je suis fidèle
proches à ma note je suis la femme de
chambre des jalouses la wii très jaloux
bien si tu découvres forme à quelques
notes répétées capable de coiffes de
larache et les yeux n'ont peut-être pas
lui arracher les yeux mais lui très
lisse en weppes pour me les mettre
comme le mari de ma tard il a laissé sa
télé radieuse dragueuse non quelle
humeur non plus à bord non c'est plus la
plus séductrice qu'elle ne sais pas je
crois que la différence entre une grande
séductrice et une grande allumeuse ou
une grande salle hop c'est que la
séductrice a pas forcément les atouts
physiques qu'à l'allumeuse la lune osé
et pour moi est forcément quelqu'un de
charnel c'est à dire que physiquement
elle fait des avances moi j'ai pas des
choses physiques
d'abord non j'ai pas le décolleté
vertigineux non mais quand même tu
largue les mecs où tu te fait larguer la
rieuse je suis pas très bien c'est pas
très large
alors tu te poser des questions encore
plus con si c'est possible tant attendu
par les questions de fond
[Musique]
pour toi le mot d'amour le plus con qu
est-ce que c'est merci encore plus vite
oui oui le mot d'amour le plus con way
to ban doit plus vite un mac et des buts
il n'a aucune chance il ya une chance
non parce que j'aime bien j'aime bien
que les choses se fassent apparaître non
dans un rythme pas forcément rapide
j'aime bien quelque chose c'est face au
tour des prévenus alors imagine
maintenant se suit les questions qu'on a
c'est un jeu imagine que tu es le choix
tu sois en dix ans soit privé de bouffe
c'est à dire tu est nourri par des
sondes intraveineuse tu ne manges pas ou
privés de sexe c'est hier que tu as les
mains attachées au lit je ne peux rien
te faire même à toi même qu'est ce que
tu choisis pas bouffer ça me gêne pas
j'ai pas si énorme bien que je bien que
j'aime bien la bouffe la bonne bouffe
j'ai peint très gros appétit et puis
chaque sexe ça me dérange pas parce que
moi je je je j'ai d'autres palliatifs
donc tu as les mains attachées au niveau
bien d'accord oui oui bon d'accord
j'ai toujours mes yeux pour voir bon
d'accord j'ai contemplatrice peut-être
pas dire voyons alors imagine soir tu
rentre tard le soir
oui tu te fais agresser
oui ça peut arriver est-ce que tu aurais
plus peur de te faire agresser par david
et john atta c'est terrible c'est
terrible licence iv où débutent les
avertissant les poissons crus de licence
permettant d'éluder johnattan ils sont
deux ils sont quatre ils sont combien
ils sont deux écoutes par des vis des
dieux montana limite je préfère parce
que je pense que je pourrais à user de
ruse et de super je choisis les plus et
moi les mois musique en moi aussi je
pourrais pas les avoir moi plus
facilement qu'en maintenant bon ils
t'ont ils t'ont fermés dans une cape de
hln c'est un jeu wii ta punition préféré
ça se paie lowrie passé l'âge ou mobiles
à fès piqué david et johnatan toujours
quelque chose arrive j'ai atteint mon
fils alors il me passe et de bosses
l'oreille il te mordre l'âge où ils te
pique la fête
les joueurs démontrent que par 13 voix
qui ne font rien à vendre et déjà fui
pour vous la même personne bon alors tu
arrive chez toi avant tu t'en fous tu
arrive chez toi hein
c'est une sorte de cauchemar tu arrives
fédérateur qu'est ce que la chose qui
ferait le plus peur ce serait en tout la
porte de chez toi
ce serait qu'il ya un rat un fantôme ou
eric charden récemment à une traîne plus
peur c'est pas un rat détermination
contre eric charden je pense que vous
attardez rares ouais je trouve ça mignon
les fantômes je crois que ça mais que
c'est très beau coup d'avoir un fantôme
c'est moi je crois que j'aurais plus
peur par richard n'aime pas ce que
vraiment je me demandais ce qu'il faut
alors maintenant tu vois et richard
dunne en rentrant chez toi tu morte de
peur ça te demandais rien c'est
l'hémorragie chez mortes des chauffeurs
vous de rire puis tu te réincarne tu
crois l'avoir informations j'essaye bon
tu te réincarné dans un objet absolument
ridicule un tut réincarnant si tu
préfères est réincarné dans le slip de
bar de chirac ou de giscard toute façon
ils doivent pas prenne prendre beaucoup
de place le snuipp soirée tranquille tu
arrêtes tes nerfs tous répondent pas
après niagara mitsouko stone et charden
un nouveau star d'high star d'enfer le
paradis de jean luc et aurélie alors
imagine que tu ne sois pas ma femme et
que tu entends de mon dernier 30 cm en
vol
tu penses quoi
[Musique]
alors une un vol pour dernier album en
fait celui qui préfère alors il fait
tellement craquer j'avais tout c'est
acheter franchement tu trouves que je
chante commandant notre duo la mort pour
qu'ils aient bien écoute pour tout
avouer je j'ai été très étonné en bien
s'attendaient à pire
et je trouve que du chanteur très très
bien ta voix lien placé sans doute un
petit peu mieux que pas mal d'autres
chanteurs ça c'est un compliment
pourtant le soir de l'enregistrement tu
as préféré partir faire un tour en moto
sur le terrain
bah oui parce que tu comprends ça se
passait pas très bien tu voulais pas
écouté ton mari
vous pensez que c'est parfait moi
j'étais en conflit avec toi avec un
ralenti qui faisait la direction
musicale puis c'est très bien moi je
voulais que tu sortes de la fin des
temps contente de spots à l'entendre et
surtout il ya pire des choses qui sait
très bien c'est de regretter ce qu'on a
fait de se dire mince si j'avais su
j'aurais pu faire dix fois mieux alors
voilà je voulais l'emmener jusqu'aux
dernières limites
évidemment tous les deux 7 ans de
mariage et tout de suite on en est venu
aux mots et je préférais partir pour te
laisser avec un ralenti tout fret
si ta mémoire et bob tu saurais que
j'avais fait que deux tirs au but
thierry effectué revenus un an 10 dans
le studio et j'ai assisté à la dernière
phrase s'il était bob quoi à la vérité
sur le port de lebu ch et le spirent
des fleurs qui sont autour je peux plus
l'oif qui nous touche elle croit plus
mais elle veut
[Musique]
qui
l'amour de quoi
m
mais non
futur tout le temps
de temps en temps
oh
giraud
à qui viennent
c'est
bien qu'ils peuvent vente n'est pas
encore
entrée
trois croix firent comme stone et
charden écoute
non parce que je suis sûr qu'on a un
autre simplement de ne plus être très
laid le vendredi à 20h30 les six
premiers mois on y suit on oublie un
petit peu quoi faste une maladie un
petit peu un véritable à télé c'est vrai
nous parle du casque est obligatoire
c'est tout un métier à haut risque la
même des primes de risque qui tombe
jamais ça m'a manqué c'est vrai j'y
pense toutefois pas spécialement
vendredi des rebelles et un petit manque
et le barça est ce que tu penses que ça
t'a aidé ou sa desservi ta carrière
être sur tf1 non je crois que ça fait
partie de ma carrière
au contraire c'est une expérience
privilégiée
c'était quand même quelque chose de rare
qu'un artiste se voit confier un horaire
aussi important pendant une année
je pense que les gens n'ont pas oublié
le chanteur la preuve
disons qu'à une empreinte un petit peu
plus forte maintenant vers la télé qui
est venu s'ajouter au reste alors bon
j'avais peur au départ d'un déport
d'image succès et puis finalement je
crois que les gens lorsqu ils aiment
bien quelqu'un de suivre je crois que ça
a rendu service à des gens on a froid
dans une balance imaginaire je le
pouvais passer très très lourd je crois
que si c'était à refaire je leur ferai
vraiment pourquoi tu es avec moi répond
parce que tu es unique qu'est ce qui est
énerve le plus chez moi ce qui m'énerve
le plus chez toi je sais cette saison
tes colères qui me font terriblement toi
tu ferais quoi si je te quitte est avec
ou sans les enfants avec moi tu me
quitterait pas et toi tu ferais quoi si
je quittais j'attendrai que tu riais est
ce que tu penses convient ira ensemble
on venait d'iran jamais tu m'aimes
je t'adore les femmes et les jours soit
volée mois soleil lunettes noires de la
semaine par local ya dans les chiottes
du pass comme par hasard ali labhar made
c'est le grand retour des grosses brice
lalonde depuis qu'il est secrétaire
d'état à l'environnement il fait beau
l'hiver et licka et véronique danseuse
au moulin rouge par véronique et davina
bande de l'or c'est le clochard ça fait
cinq ans qu'il essayait de rentrer au
palace effet happy birthday samba sens
premier album titre tube stop bientôt
top
moi personnellement ça me plaît
énormément aux vertus qu'amélie
c'est une oeuvre du peintre n'auront
d'yeux
[Musique]
de là
et
[Musique]
ce nom
watsco et non
[Musique]
non
wen hui est là
battus
des endroits
oh
[Applaudissements]
à défaut
tha
l'effort
k
[Musique]
toi tu es
sow
[Musique]
mme ashton
m
piqué
oh
ah bon
[Applaudissements]
mais pas
ou pas
[Musique]
n'est ce pas
m
ga
[Musique]
je
thébaux
m
oh
ça
débat
k
[Musique]
m
anti portrait chinois navarre la bagarre
arrange le portrait de la rive gauche
jean edern bhl sollers
tout le monde y laisse des plumes la
barre grand soir n'est pas bien là moi
je vais très bien la maladie est très
toujours très présente dans le tournoi
parce que je me souviens des loukoums y
avait un dénommé rask était victime de
dames syfy comme tu disais à l'époque
ensuite il ya eu cette histoire du sida
où il ya dans un bouquin on a écrit que
ça fait la route du sida on a dix
navarre al siyassa te dis mais attendez
c'est pas vrai j'ai pas le sida et tu as
obtenu d'ailleurs complet qu'on coupe
les pages que non je parle j'ai obtenu
simplement qu'on retourne du livre de
novembre oui j'étais [ __ ] j'avais eu une
congestion cérébrale paix des étrangers
sur cérébrale sida oui je le sais
puisque deux premiers à le croire
c'était ma famille parce que je les ai
pas vus oui j'ai pas vu parce que
j'avais le site à le [ __ ] socialise la
famille avait le sida
donc on n'avait pas le voir et
curieusement comme j'ai comprise ont
quand même venu une fois à chacun mais
de frais et j'ai compris que j'avais pas
envie que je vis vous avez envie que je
me passe que la cupidité ça existe en
france et samatanais terriblement envie
c'est comme ça je m'en suis sorti les
l'écrire
écrire en général on me dit qu'elle est
votre meilleur roman en question idiote
on dit pas une mère de famille quel est
le plus beau de vos enfants alors je
réponds je réponds c'est celui que je
vais écrire et bien pour la première
fois jeudi c'est celui jeu vient
d'éclore c'est l'hôtel stx et chez albin
michel alors à contenu puisque l'hôtel
stick c'est quand même un hôtel le nom
comme ça stx a fait partie des noms qui
à la fois on peut très bien les trouver
d'ailleurs sur une façade de cinéma oui
mais les investigations il a fait et
puis on peut c'est aussi la mythologie
grecque raconte nous un peu cet hôtel
stx dont on ne revient pas l'hôtel stx
et un hôtel où on entre et on est su on
n'en sort pas en douceur
on ne sait pas quand on ne sait pas
comment ai je n'ai pas pris un
échantillon représentatif de la
population française pour écrire mon
roman comme aurait pu le faire
quelqu'un qui ferait écrire un roman de
marketing
je les écris sans m'en rendre compte
d'abord un roman on ne décide pas de
l'écrire on se retrouve ayant écrit un
roman je me suis retrouvé fin juillet
ayant écrit pendant deux mois j'aurais
nuit hôtel stx il ya une foule de
personnages qui se sont les personnages
de la foule c'est bien je n'ai pas pris
un ambassadeur un hors-série nano 1g pas
pris une vieille [ __ ] mondaine devenue
duchesse j'ai pas non j'ai pris des gens
les gens que j'aime
des gens de partout tout le monde les
hommes des femmes des et puis à la
patronne de l'hôtel stx et puis il ya
son fils
scaron caron évidemment puisque c'est
caron qui fait traverser le styx n'est
ce pas mais tu connais le portrait
chinois dont elle tenterait chinois
c'est quand tu si je te disais par
exemple les abats et si tu étais une
fleur d'orchidée on va faire la version
affaires nantis portrait chinois
oui
[Musique]
si tu étais un défaut du srec lb
mangeurs de gâteaux site était une
injure charognards c'était une maladie
isolement si c'était un insecte
sreg mouche pourquoi
parce que les mouches l'empêcher de
travailler quand j'écrivais way et que
les mouches son opiniâtre reviennent
toujours semaine infernale
là où il faut pas c'est infernal une
louche et nous vous empêche de faire la
sienne une mouche peux t'empêcher de
faire un lieu si tu étais un assassin je
serai soit bernard henri lévy soit
philippe soler soit jean edern hallier
je tuerai l'esprit c'était une arme je
serai une arme blanche très aiguisé
comme les crayons je taime crayon tous
les soirs vous en aller me coucher ça
m'étonne pas si tu étais un poison
je serai critique littéraire est un
collabo
je serai français tu vois qu'il est bien
ce jeu et si tu étais un supplice tu
serais quel supplice libre je serai
directeur de rubrique littéraire dans un
grand magasin et si j'étais un accident
pour finir
je continuerai à écrire quand on
débarque à paris cent ans radis la seule
chose à faire pour un ben là qui sait de
l'asie ce qui va encore plus vite c'est
de faire une reprise micky a choisi gaby
bergman ou mosman avoue du g15
[Musique]
j'fais mon footing au milieu des actes
et des coraux et je fais mes pompes sur
les restes d'un vieux kabush qui au fond
jour faut bien que je me voyais semanya
nation prise par je m'écrase le des glo
gimont contrat conscience par ses fans
optique faut jouer du bon jean farret
qui lie
[Musique]
veux pas me laisser là
amer je fais des conneries
je chante amer
dans le long des cols
[Musique]
tu fais ce n'est pas clair
au caire dans les résultats check up
rocha qui se met plus à rallumer son
club ça me fait rire
il faut savoir dire stop
tu sais c'est comme ce type qui
voulaient que je reçois des médicaments
dans son club au mois d'août en escouade
chante comme ta vie
les voix de nikki
[Musique]
pas me laisser aller
attends je fais des conneries
je chante la mer
le long d
[Musique]
tu sais c'est pas clair
non
cabu je t'ai déjà dit est bien plus
belle que maurice tête
québec comme ab tac attend plus qu'une
allumette rhin faisait craquer les
pompiers
aujourd'hui c'est vendredi et je
voudrais me promène je vais encore si
les vendeurs c'est irène et ses sirènes
[Musique]
tu ne devrais pas me laisser
j'vois pas dormir je déconne
les longs
l'on décolle pas
tu sais c'est pas clair
[Musique]
leur route vers l'afrique si t'as pas
les bonnes ça sert à gauche n'hésite pas
à parler pour beaucoup en boule
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les mois
tu te plains me
ramadan
[Musique]
gaby oh gaby c'était mal qui gon mais
lui maintenant jean paul gaultier l auto
interview je te plairait si tu me
rencontrer
[Musique]
dans quel sens dans le sens sexuel
sexuellement par le nom et pas assez
musclé est ce qu'au delà d'une mode n'a
pas inventé une tête une tête de turc
oui peut-être pour certaines personnes
tu crois que tu es un créateur de génie
où l'apôtre du mauvais goût
bon il facilement je dirais peut-être
apôtres du mauvais goût mais encore je
sais pas très bien ce que c'est que le
mauvais goût et de bon goût vent
créateur de génie là je dois dire que je
crois pas je crois pas qu'il y ait de
génie qu'il ya beaucoup de travail et
surtout ça très fatigué d'ailleurs pas
ce travail non j'aime toujours autant
mais enfin ça me fatigue physiquement
donc créateur de génie c'est parce que
c'est non plus vraiment à création
est-ce que tu ne serait pas le premier
couturier de l'ère de la télévision je
sais pas si je suis le premier en tous
les cas c'est sûr que je me suis enfin
que je le suis en tous les cas de l'ère
de la télévision
si je dois dire depuis que je suis gamin
je regarde la télé tout le temps tout en
tout temps et encore maintenant je la
regarde tout le temps je crois que c'est
la télévision en fin de compte qui n'a
et les médias qui m'a appris le métier
je n'ai pas fait d'école c'est la télé
c'est à dire qu'en fin de compte les
émissions d'avertis dim dam dom aussi
qui m'ont appris en fin de compte ce que
je fais tu ne penses pas que dans les
années 80 on a un peu trop divinisé le
chiffon tout est à chaque fois tout est
exagéré dans tous les sens dans les
années 70 par contre il était
complètement renier alors qu'en fin de
compte y ait des gens qui prétendaient
ne pas être à la mode ni suivre la mode
alors qu'en fin de compte ils étaient
les archétypes même de la mode des
années 70 c'est à dire le côté look
jeans avec le cheveu long comme ça et
genre je m'en fous je suis en dehors de
la mode et de l'art ni bon donc c'était
en fin de compte il était très à la mode
quand même
maintenant on dit la mode partout on dit
que les créateurs sont des rock stars
presque même quand ils font pas dit ce
qui est tu as combien de fashion victim
sur la conscience les fashion victimes à
la fois je les aime bien et ça m'effraie
un petit peu aussi bon je les aime bien
pourquoi parce que ça prouve en fin de
compte une espèce car ça peut être parce
que l aime beaucoup ce que je fais dans
ces cas là c'est flatteur j'aime bien
évidemment parcours aussi la fashion
victim c'est simplement parce que un nom
qu'on doit porter à tout prix
qu'on doit porter à tout prix parce que
c'est le moment de le porter et tout ça
ça je déteste cette arrive souvent de
porter une de tes jupe pour homme oui je
suis tombé une fois dans un escalier
d'ailleurs je suis pris les pieds dedans
après j'ai essayé la chape ce bon ben la
chape ce site veut combien d ouverture
c'est un petit peu plus facile
donc là j'ai même pu danser avec enfin
la jupe pour homme je l'avais pas fait
au départ en pensant que le monde entier
que tous les gens dans la rue portrait
la jupe pour homme je l'avais fait
surtout bombardé depuis part parce que
c'était une envie qui correspondait à un
peu à certaines personnes que je voyais
et puis à moi aussi à apporter d'avoir
été très masculine le cours a été porté
avec des costumes avec une cravate ou il
ya un trois-pièces carrément et mais en
fin de compte il était surtout parce que
c'est symbolisait en fin de compte le
fait qu'il ya plein de garçons qui
voulaient est habillé de façon un petit
peu différente et pas seulement avec des
des petits costumes étriqués pour quel
genre vient d'ailleurs quand madame la
commission tu fais 20 milliards de
centimes de chiffre d'affaires tu fais
quoi tout ce pognon
ben écoute alors absolument rien c'est
ça qui est dramatique c'est je n'ai
aucune imagination pour les dépenser
alors c'est pas moi qu'il se dépense
je vais pas dire que j'ai des espèce de
sangsue et alentours de moi donc c'est
pas ça non je crois que tout cet argent
là va comment
tu entends des projets dans des choses
comme ça si tu veux mais seul luxe en
vérité parce que j'ai pas de besoin je
pourrais dans une chambre de bonne j'ai
toujours essayé tout à fait vrai c'est
pas que je veux dire mon dieu c'est un
impôt parce que font passer une vertu du
tout j'aime bien des gens qui dépensent
que ça vient aussi après tout l'argent
on en fait toujours ici une espèce de
complexe d'avoir de l'argent vous
dépenser de l'argent
tout ça est en fin de compte tout cas
après tout l'attitude des américains et
dans un sens beaucoup plus honnête que
la nôtre bon donc j'ai pas du tout ce ce
complexe là ce qu'il ya c'est que j'ai
pas dans vie quand on me demande même
comme cadeau qu'est ce que je voudrais
c'est pas que j'ai tout pas du tout mais
j'ai pas vraiment d'environ fin de
compte ma plus grande envie c'était de
faire ce métier je le fais tu prépares
quoi pour le prochain film de peter
greenaway avec richard bohringer et ben
je prépare tous les costumes et c'est un
sacré boulot
un sacré boulot pourquoi parce que
monsieur greenway à une idée géniale
génial génial génial c'est de bon chaque
pièce il ya une cuisine ça se passe dans
une cuisine une salle de restaurant un
jardin à une autre pièce encore des
quatre pièces chaque fois une couleur
différente et toutes les personnes du
film à chaque fois qu'il passe dans la
pièce prennent la couleur de la pièce
sur leurs vêtements qui viennent tout
blanc quand ils sont dans la cuisine
tout rouge quand ils sont dans la salle
de restaurant ce qui veut dire que tous
les vêtements doivent être multipliés
par quatre tu as déclaré que tu était
saturé par la récupération des grandes
causes par le showbiz c'est bien
l'opportunisme aussi parce que la mode
c'est aussi l'opportunisme je veux être
quelquefois quand c'est vraiment une
espèce d'évidence que maintenant il faut
trouver ça bien et maintenant il faut
s'intéresser à cela je préfère les gens
en fin de compte qui s'intéresse depuis
un moment qu'il découvre pas vingt ans
après tout le monde
un blouson cuir avec un tutu c'est déjà
du sampling tu as suivi la même démarche
pourtant disque exactement t'as tout
compris
c'est tout à fait ça c'est à dire que
bonjour je faisais les bandes sons de
mais des filets en coupant comme ça et
en prenant l'introduction d'un morceau
et tout c'est un petit peu un vol en fin
de compte et mélangeant quelquefois avec
même des bandes sons de films et puis
voilà et puis dans mes shows ç'a
toujours été un petit peu quand même
comme des comme des spectacles
ça te fait quoi de savoir que ton dix
matches sera beaucoup moins bien que tes
vêtements
d'abord c'est pas sûr que ça marche
moins bien
une fois n'est pas coutume voici
nightclubbing starring le plus beau
carnaval de la capitale celui du palace
la vie la vie sera un carnaval pour vous
si vous allez au palais des sports le 13
février pour voir blue oyster cult rouge
[Musique]
ravi est un jeu jours la ville est en
jeu je joue avec randy newman à la
cigale le mercredi 15 du doigt on va
montrer du doigt johnny thunder à paris
au palace le mercredi 22 février 89 que
j'ai de tout recours n'est pas ce que je
les ai foiré
savez-vous le nom bizarre que ces
messieurs monte au nez bonsoir monsieur
et rendez vous le mardi 14 pour la saint
valentin sur les champs elysées but de
l'opération embrasser 1000 couples de 9
à 19 heures alors valérie hainaut
françois rennard et marie-odile briller
vous publiez un requin chez calmann lévy
qui s'appelle pour en finir avec les
années 80 qui est assez drôle
[Musique]
temps
via une méchanceté qui sont dites sur
moi non mais non mais c'est ça la salle
assez drôle je me suis marré en lui
disant alors ça se passe comment la
promotion là jusqu'à maintenant
pour l'instant ça se passe bien on
croise des boues - ont tous les
fauteuils de fenêtres quand on touche du
bois ça se passe bien ouais
qu'est-ce qui vous demandent les gens en
général ils nous demandent en général la
première question alors on peut vous
demander de me poser si vous voulez
c'est pourquoi vous dites que les années
80 sont finis alors qu'elles sont pas
finis ah oui d'accord je vous répondre
voilà un beau dakar
alors pourquoi vous dites que les années
80 sont finis alors je ne sens pas que
j'écris je vous remercie de cette
question thierry son c'est la réf
non on répond on répond en général que
vous allez repetto toutes prêtes pour
toutes les questions je ne prends pas
joue sur celle-là on sait à peu près on
a le sentiment que les modes de vivre en
train de changer
oui que les modèles qui ont caractérisé
des années 80 c'était bon le monde des
punks d'abord la branchitude après est
en train de changer maintenant on parle
t on parle du cocooning value rodin au
coq on va en parler aux rêves l'europe
pays domestiques comme ça ça prouve que
ça change il ya aussi des personnages
dans des pertes à chanteuse du centre
des années 80 qui sont en train de
changer un peu à la fois il ya par
exemple la célèbre la fameuse marguerite
dbv sans doute remarqué que ça qu'au
moins 15 jours d'interview ouais si un
signe qui ne trompe pas allumé dans ce
qu'il faut dire c'est ça que vous
appelez ça une petite sociologie des
stones us de l'époque et vous allumez
tout le monde c'est à dire c'est la fin
la tequila des halles au gel du loft
paul morand le pot encore une fois ça
fait deux fois à la libération avec un
philippe starck jean paul gaultier gras
tout net le teint blême pour pu avoir le
teint blême et les bars clubs et les
bains mais là où vous êtes honnête je
dois dire c'est qu'à la fin du bouquin
j'ai passé ma honnête je ne sais pas
mais à la fin du bouquin vous dites
quand même tous les trois que les bains
vous envie
du mal mais que finalement vous devez
toujours été refoulé à l'entrée que
c'est habile ce qui nous amène en
prenant tout de suite d'activités
l'alimentation alors les années 80 c'est
le saumon cru mariné à l'aneth
on a encore c'est le chichiteux ben
ouais c'est à dire que effectivement on
mange alors qu'est ce qu'on a trouvé
d'autre que sont montrés marignane est
là et ça c'est terrible et années 80 je
suis en mini portion d'un moment j'ai
mais il ya l'histoire ce n'est pas sous
la forme sur ses pas tellement la ligne
c'est la forme de particuliers dans les
années 80 c'est qu'on s'est mis à faire
du sport avant le regarde à la télé et
heureusement on en fait une révolution
au pharmacien tendance et oui pour les
manger dans conditions mais plus
seulement sont son short satiné pour
regarder rugby ne laissez jamais dit le
cinéma le cinéma mais là c'est difficile
de voir une tendance voir ce qu'étaient
les deux les deux piliers du cinéma des
années 80 afin d'esthétique 87 bernex et
besson ouais c'est ça aussi c'est
probablement c'est tout doit être
calculée au millimètre
il faudrait le la tomate soie rouge
comme dans l'étude pour madonna on
dirait que le sang qui tombe de l'oeil
de comment il s'appelle la bêtise et à
la sda soit aussi rouge que la tomate
qui est dans le qui est filmé pour le
film mcdonald's évoque cette esthétique
faible politiquement la bougie aller
carrément sont cuites nous on aime bien
mitterrand est-ce que d'abord ils vont
en vacances en france
ensuite il y as ap on lui proposait un
loft faubourg saint-honoré il a préféré
gaston petit pingouin appartement rue
lièvre il veut pas parler des
différences qu'il s'agisse des
ordinateurs ap le bouquet mais quelqu'un
qui dit à placer leurs centrales aux
années 90 pour vous c'est vrai c'est
épouvantable moi je tiens public et non
c'est cette histoire de coucou ni le roi
de la nuit je sais pas dans tous les cas
sûrement pas couleur que vous dites que
les pins du début des 80 ils sont
devenus le crooner de la fin des 80
d'être beau pour la fois mais qu'est ce
que c'est cette histoire de kooning tous
les magazines féminins nous rabat les
oreilles seront faits dans les années 80
dans le trip nightclubbers est normal
que les gens réagissent et on vous a
beaucoup convivial pour monde je pense
que c'est ça qu'on en parle beaucoup on
en parle comme réaction évidemment c'est
trop ennuyeux parce que les recettes du
pot-au-feu dans le figaro madame
elle c'est insupportable
le pot-au-feu rennes son image illustre
m ça me plaît beaucoup c'est à dire
qu'on se marre toujours bien là mais
quoi je joue en portent garants et et
moi c'est comme on les appelle les
couleurs des patates de alors grande
question mon cher françois
qu'est ce qu'un branché pas branché
c'est quelqu'un qui est qui qui était
qu'ils étaient sérieux sur des choses
futiles qui était temps cieux sans
fondement superficie était profondément
cinéaste voilà oui
wouah warhol était branché avant la
lettre ouais c'est ça c'est les gens qui
sont dans la langue et au logis warhol
voilà c'est ça hein branché alors est ce
que finalement le mot franchise et être
usée mais est-ce que c'est pas non c'est
pas ça aussi on essayait câble et
satellite et rendez vous savez ils
meurent aussi
mais qu'est ce qu'il te demande pardon
c'est l'image est ce que finalement
quand vous critiquez les gens branchés
cette fois les manches et ces gens qui
s'intéressent à ce qui est nouveau à ce
qui sort nouveau film heaven musique est
ce que ce n'est pas désespérée l'avant
garde
non parce qu'un jour important de
fashion victim s'adapteront de suivre
parce qu'il faut des gens qui avaient
capté les premiers skippers de tous les
goûts à la petite semaine dans ce
précipice tête baissée parce qu'à
l'avant garde et très bien mais
maintenant il est branché c'est très en
forme il me brancher toute allusion que
les avant gardes alors on peut dire que
pour l'instant pas si l'avant garde ses
surnoms et qu'aucun heures alors dans la
farce ans ouais ils vont pouvoir sortir
les premiers il faut toujours admiré
l'avant-garde heureusement qu'elle est
là ça c'est tout à fait juste que tu
alors il ya un truc que je le dis à
françois
tu travailles à libé bon y'a rien contre
libératrice a fait la connaissance du
monde il le reconnaît il
boyzone un boys band a dit amir so when
you die for music in iraq and you had
maniaque c'est dans l'un des terminaux
mobiles famous un bridge bank et irish
chris bell offre 10 vainqueurs du retour
involved in rock and roll ou cette date
french cycling rock'n roll is like
japanese go into it in america holdings
nv doivent sans cesse
oui aux autres
c'est vers les provinces show in so for
as we are not trying to copy working
holiday visa aux musicals route de
discipline france musique est juste not
going back to the roots music live at
the catcher in portier hadjaoui qui
ouvre michael pena coûtant nude chaque
indice 606 2010 because it has come from
your août
ils sont 6 16% new york state and you
can do you be there it right wing chun
yung-woo album culte flag et news a été
de mosquées l'eau envahir album what it
means flag is like moto x yonah martin
et de la vérité fiscaux situation so
music for everybody with puis à 505 et
savenay
en somme les rues de los trifouiller
zied maupas briques success if the
success is like it people sera hugo
descat aux cannois aux cailloux kg anaïs
pong aux animaux
un dessin bungalows means d'abidjan et
ceux qui vivent des situations
responsable oui mike loughlin succès spa
sauna gay est ce qu a innové interview
with your eyes of any c'est ce programme
est ce que le who's who interview
telio ou au new music is enough défendre
vos news
ok d'abord tous les dialogues is using
high tech new technology mit donc ok to
get rich or white writer
[Musique]
oui
using the love baby blacks
développement à new delhi
tout individu et america est une des
spécialistes testing droit du 4 ou 2 x
noël et le mark wahlberg princeton
princeton où il avait trois autres îles
giniès conglomerate of aucun sauf des
friandises et brillante writing and the
shining et best of breed midget a box
ils feront un listing des sprints date
pris part aux biffins offert aux enfants
et équivaut se marient aux drogues et
les ovnis de canaux funky jazzy rock et
pop music awards son mini album last but
not least jimi hendrix maskoutains
just to show dont 10 points il est tout
seul
taris diario as to find de l'accès
physique aux arrêts aloft un risque
alors qu'eminem greenpeace
et lulu rochford manaswing lambda
mammouth et rennes
après tout bien fort d'hamouma calme ou
mac pasadena ce bazar dix ans n'est plus
fait preuve
c'est dans l'une est que vous les avez
vus pour la première fois il ya quatre
mois
rochefort quatre bouteilles rochford
d'accord du road forte d'abord
sommet
kossi agassa
botero
m
thiam
d
c'est de la blague
comment
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c
[Applaudissements]
et
aulaqi
m
[Musique]
rome
mais
pour la guerre
m
comme on aime
oui
[Musique]
oh
le lait
les gars
m
[Musique]
tu mens
béni
[Applaudissements]
d
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
tiens
mais ça
il attend
[Musique]
le monsieur cinéma du rock'n'roll avec
philippe dana alors philippe tu animé
l'année dernière une émission sur m6
c'était qui s'appelait dan haram a été
très bien c'est vrai mais je suis
content de l'entendre
bah oui pourquoi il pense dépasser il
pensait pas ça chez m6
si penser ça mais il pensait qu'elle
coûtait trop cher et qu'elle faisait
passer d'audience moi j'ai un réacteur
que était programmé un horaire tellement
invraisemblable que toute façon elle
risquait pas de se rendre à 10 je leur
ai dit il faut garder à partir de
maintenant tu fais sixties sur europe 1
ouais alors avec gérard aujourd'hui pis
tu fais sur canal+ une émission qui
s'appelle ça cartoon
c'est un karting depuis trois ans le
dessin animé de qualité a wave venir sur
ces les cartoons américains de la grande
époque donc c'est au moment où hollywood
est à son apogée
les réalisateurs de cartoon ont des
trucs formidables
alors ça nous amène directement à notre
ami frank margerin alors sans toi tu
fais tellement de trucs on va prendre
juste ce que tu viens de faire parce
qu'on aimerait tellement faire loria
indice de dennis ruy ce qu'est le groupe
de rock dans lequel kühne gens qui
s'appellent de toutes les larmes du ciel
tout chaud a écrit par dodo et villemin
dont classique et dvd parce que c'est un
show d'enfer et la fête alors là tu es
responsable c'est frank margerin
présente d'humanoïdes associés alors il
ya un tas de dessinateurs maternelle
ouais là une preuve d'un châle vérité le
calme du cher dinars
bon alors vous êtes près les enfants
[Musique]
on va commencer avec toi les homonymes
du rock c'est facile ça tu aimes cité de
reading au this way
otis redding ça s'appelle we otis
redding et
otis redding
vu que j'étais peut-être un petit peu
une lettre y en a qui jouait avec jimi
hendrix experience
[Musique]
car leur ai dit tu sais toi
non pas question à saissac et selon une
lettre au roi du tir toi tu m'avais dit
que tu me soufflerait angers 1 0 lens et
noel redding qui était le bassiste
j'avais fait un bon on lui un tout petit
peu à moitié fait de voir comment bon
alors à toi maintenant tu veux citer
deux mitchell du rock
ouais sans compter et jimmy choo est
entendue alors c'est dommage poussée du
chômage s'était fait si les sentais bien
je vais t'aider encore iéna qui jouait
avec jimi hendrix experience dans les
jambes et j'en connais jean michel que
la peinture
dany michel joni mitchell ça fait on
l'applaudît 2010 championne du conflit
chronique et l'autre surface il convient
d'en parler jimi hendrix experience
spesa cette fois c'était le batteur tu
sais pas quoi vous adapter à égalité ça
vous fait un demi point chacun c'était
le batteur c'était mitch mitchell se
confondre avec mick micheyl
alors maintenant on va faire les
reprises jazzy dit manfred mann 64 ça a
été repris sous quel titre est parti ou
les copains je ne vous oublierai jamais
voilà j'ai lâché la bravo
[Applaudissements]
it's my party lesley gore en 60 richard
anthony a wish en tennis c'est
manquerait travaux alors la verrerie one
hit wonder sur les morceaux qui ont été
des gens qu'on fait un tube dans leur
vie les one hit wonder alors on va
commencer avec toi héloïse en 68
héloïse c'est pas un one hit wonder
sembas à one hit wonder dans la mesure
où le mec a fait ça il n'a jamais fait
que ça n'a plus jamais entendu parler ah
ben alors je me trompe alors tu sais toi
penser à vas-y non mais c'est à peu près
depuis ses marges aux ragots a marqué là
tu sais pas dit le je pense à bari 1-1
way
[Applaudissements]
c'est sa question liste black is black
en 65 repris par d'unia l'idée bien sûr
c'était qui la version originale black
is black arles a pourtant ça c'est
facile sachez simplement que ça
m'échappe
c'est un monde espagnol ouais là sont
l'ocelot ce casque blouson marron
cheveux c'est la panique c'est pas le
style de l'osce a pris conscience de soi
los angeles non c'est pas le scra douce
c'est pas losc à dos c'est l'os à moelle
c'est pas l'os à moelle ces mondes
parisienne l'ossature
alors maintenant on va faire pour le
super pactole on va faire les
supergroupes or si je te dis un groupe
dans lequel il ya stevie winwood dave
massol jim capaldi et chris wood
c'est pas le souhaitent sur davies bout
non ça c'était juste avant et que gm bec
trafic
ouais alors à toi maintenant clapton
d'eric clapton ginger baker eric greff
chausseur la grèce ouais bon voilà on
les applaudit
c'est la vie quand il joue sur ma tête
c'est l'enfer
quand je tombe pas de taksim c'est là
ouais c'est ça la nouvelle eve rue
fontaine à pigalle dj albert c'est lui
qui chante
quant à
la valette la faune au fond
[Musique]
à leogane
a toujours par ali mais c'est la vie
c'est comme ça c'est comme ça
à
ça c'est absolument épouvantable c'est
la passion de jean jeanne vécue par jean
louis costes
l'histoire d'un enfant drogué [ __ ] rejeté
par sa famille est devenu prêtre
intégriste pour punir le monde
masturbation son ami tout est bon pour
jean louis costes 34 ans 3 album under
ground à son actif il vit de sa musique
de 1000 francs par mois ça s'invente pas
[Musique]
e
non
[Musique]
à
m
[Musique]
tu es
cela et french lovers l usine éphémère
rue david d'angers et
dans gîte ou les alternatifs était là au
concert des french lover et même les
[ __ ] vertes en envoyé spécial ce
que vous entendez là ses sens
[Musique]
premier concert de et skate club à paris
au pass le jeudi 16 février 1989 à 20h30
précises mesdames messieurs
savez vous que 8% des femmes rêvent de
faire l'amour dans une baignoire remplie
de champagne qu'elles sont 10% qui
rêvent d'assouvir leurs fantasmes avec
leurs supérieurs hiérarchiques dans
n'importe quelle posture et à n'importe
quel endroit
valérie au boulot
[Musique]
oui roi
m
oui
bah
kodwa
bright bright
wade
[Musique]
drake
oui 3
[Musique]
oui
m
pas
oh
wade
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu